it was the box office smash that made us
all too scared to go back in the water
but the making of the movie jaws was a
cinematic drama in and of itself
last week a new play opened in london
that tells the tale of just how
traumatic it all really was as charlie
dagda found out it's a uniquely personal
story
[Music]
never before have two simple notes
struck such a terrifying chord
but the tale of a bloodthirsty great
white on the prowl you're gonna need a
bigger boat was smooth sailing compared
to the drama unfolding behind the scenes
you think you're overworked do you
you think you're over stretched
you beverly hills milk puffs well do you
the shark is broken takes a deep dive
into what has become hollywood lore
surrounding jaws an infamous feud
between lead actors robert shaw richard
dreyfuss and roy scheider worsened by
the continuous breakdown of the
mechanical shark and the ambitions of a
25 year old newbie director by the name
of steven spielberg
why have so many people i don't know
identified with it or picked up on it or
i think it's because jaws has such a
place in our culture and history after a
wildly successful run in edinburgh they
were gonna need a bigger stage which is
when it hit london's west end you may
have noticed a man playing grizzled
shark hunter quint bears a striking
resemblance to the legendary actor
robert shaw himself his son ian co-wrote
the play and plays his mercurial father
and it wasn't easy it goes from light to
dark and dark to light and sometimes it
does it like that you know where
does your father end and quint begin to
be fair we stole from jaws
you know
which is an astonishing film
partly because of the rhythm of the film
it never lets you settle you don't know
what's coming next you don't know when
to be frightened you know or to laugh
um
or whether he should be laughing exactly
so charlie welcome aboard the orc the
entire stage performance bobs along in
the confinement of the cabin of the orca
we have half a door
built to the exact dimensions of the
original boat
the tensions were well documented in the
book by carl gottlieb but as a
six-year-old visiting the set ian never
got it when i was a kid i thought they
all got on very well i don't think it
was really until i met richard dreyfuss
and i introduced myself as
ian shaw son of robert
and his reaction wasn't
particularly
like he didn't reach out to hug me or
anything like that you know
some scars run deep in the movie and the
play robert shaw's character had mckismo
turned to 11.
robert listen i
i never got a chance to say before but i
just wanted to tell you how much i loved
your claudius it was the best claudius
i've ever seen
do you think i could do shakespeare
no it wasn't just a case of them
um hating each other it was almost as if
robert wanted to school him
you know to to teach him how to be
an actor and dare i say a man a little
man like you can't carry that amount of
fat you're a disgrace i bet you couldn't
even do ten press-ups what is this west
point or even five i'll give you a
hundred dollars right now if you can do
five press-ups all right richard no no
if he wants to see there were times that
i wasn't sure
whether richard dreyfuss was
being intentionally annoying or if he
was
really scared
hold it up he's coming straight for us
don't screw it up now don't wait for me
you can almost see that he's building up
the courage within those moments to
deliver what he delivers which we now
know to be a
phenomenal performance much of the
tension was compounded by robert shaw's
well-known alcoholism laid bare on stage
oh god no while ian didn't shy away from
the demons that haunted his father and
took him away when he was just nine it
wasn't something that haunted his
childhood
no i remember a very affectionate loving
dad i have to say
do you feel that you paid homage to your
affectionate living death i hope so
i hope so
it's been said jaws was never just a
movie about a shark
quit
no maybe this isn't just a play about
the movie for cbs saturday morning
charlie dagetta london
i can't get over the likeness
robert shaw and ian shaw and also how
affectionately he talks about his dad
his dad who died at the age of 51. i'd
go see that i would in a heartbeat
because it holds us deep back to that
childhood thing it takes me right back
you never go in the water never don't
think about that the original summer
blockbuster yeah
that's right